(upbeat music)
(grunting)
- Nice dude.
Fuck yeah son, own that shit.
- Ah dude, dude do you see how
fuckin' ripped I look on this thing?
- Dude I do, I fuckin' see,
you look yolked as fuck, dude.
How much weight you got on there?
- Oh I didn't put any on dude.
I'm still gettin' warm or whatever.
- Nice dude, smart.
Fuckin' treat your body right.
Hey, hit this.
- Mmm.
- Yeah right?
- That's good dude, what is this?
- Whey protein, soy
protein, nonfat milk, ice,
marshmallow fluff,
Nutella, and Goldschlager.
- Look at you dude fuckin'
Bobby Flay over there.
- Oh thank you dude.
Yeah dude, like I know it's
more of like a cocktail
or whatever but like, I'm
hydrating so whatever.
- Yeah dude, for sure.
- Hey fellas, you mind
if we hop in for a sec?
- Sorry dude we're right
in the middle of a set.
- Yeah so, no offense, but fuck you.
- Whoa dude, we're just we're
just trying to work out.
- What did you just say, dude?
- Is this for real?
- Oh fuck dude,
my fucking chains are about to break.
- Sorry, we didn't mean to
cause any trouble fellas.
- Oh no?
Well then, mission not
accomplished asshole!
- We fucking get it bros, you
think you're better than us.
- Fuck dude.
Fuck!
- I get so fuckin' tired of
everyone else bro.
- It's just so sad, you know.
Like it makes me not even
wanna come to the gym.
Ow!
- Dude, you think we're fat dude?
- What?
No, do you?
- No.
- Good!
Fuck.
- This smoothie's fuckin' yummy dude.
- Right?
I'm like legit drunk right now.
(upbeat techno music)
- Hey what's up guys?
- What's up fuckers?
- Thanks so much for watching our videos.
- There's no need to thank them cause
it was fuckin' sick dude, like
they should be thanking us.
- Yeah dude, yeah where's
my fuckin' thank you dude?
- You're welcome.
- Yeah fuckin' you're welcome dude
Oh, and fuckin' freeloaders?
Stop watching our videos
and like not sharing
or fucking subscribing.
- Yeah dude, fuckin' post that
shit on your Facebook and Twitter.
- What the fuck dude, hey
here's a fuckin' thought,
here's a fuckin' light bulb for you dude.
Fuckin' click the link on my dick
to fuckin' subscribe, dude.
- Fuck yeah dude, yeah
click this dick.
- Click my fuckin' dick dude.
- Click this dick.
Hey dude, fuckin' click my dick, dude.